coming up on 5 17 on your Tuesday
morning you know families all over the
valley look forward to a special
calendar with Student Art for each month
from kindergarten through 12th grade I
had the honor once again of hosting the
Happy Times Calendar reveal for 2023
which includes a new record
there were more than 3
000 entries from art students throughout
Las Vegas depicting an event that makes
them happy let's hear it for the brand
new record
so every student whose art appears in
the calendar had their original work
framed to take home with a photo
opportunity for them in their respective
art teachers at the event put on by the
Unity College of Education so the Happy
Times Calendar is available at Silver
State Schools Credit Union offices for
two dollars a piece proceeds go to the
Credit Union's people over profits
Foundation that focuses on education in
the community as well as financial
literacy uh give some of those to share
to take a look at too but John and
Heather just been going over it yeah
Blown Away by the talents wow and the
other thing that's really cool for
teachers because it is the Silver State
Schools Credit Union yeah on on the
actual calendar it has the the pay
period for the teachers throughout the
school district I love that I like it so
no that day that's a good day at the
beach yeah I like that take a look at
October because the one for Halloween is
just unbelievable but it's hard to pick
a favorite because all of those students
are so talented
and the shading I mean it is remarkable
look at how well they draw people look
at that that's amazing that's fantastic
so talented let me get to October right
quick that's beautiful